.
AND MANY DON'T LIKE THAT IDEA.
>>
TO THEIR ALL RIGHT, GUSTAVO VAL,
THANKS SO MUCH FOR YOUR
REPORTING THERE IN MEXICO.
THE JANUARY 6TH SELECT
COMMITTEE APPEARS READY TO
CRIMINALLY REFER FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT.
AND THAT IS NOT ALL.
A SOURCE TELLING CNN THE PANEL
IS ALSO SET TO ASK THE DOJ TO
CONSIDER UPFRONT CHARGES OF
OBSTRUCTING AN OFFICIAL
PROCEEDING AND CONSPIRACY TO
DEFRAUD THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
A NEW CHAPTER IN THIS LEGAL
SAGA FOR THE FORMER PRESIDENT
--
SO, WITH US NOW TO TALK ABOUT
THIS AND WHAT IT ALL MEANS IS
FORMER FEDERAL PROSECUTOR AND
NOW DEFENSE ATTORNEY SHAN RUE.
SO, LET'S BREAK THIS DOWN FIRST
OF ALL.
IF MERRICK GARLAND, THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL, GETS THESE
REFERRALS, WHAT WITH THE NEXT
STEPS THE?
>> THE NEXT STEP IN THIS CASE
IS PROBABLY TO PUNT THE ROLE TO
JACK SMITH, BECAUSE THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL, BECAUSE HE IS THE
PERSON WHO WOULD REALLY BE
SERVING AS HEAD OF THE JANUARY
SIX INVESTIGATION RIGHT NOW AS
WELL AS THE MAR-A-LAGO ONES.
THEY WOULD THEN LOOK AT THIS --
I THINK, WITH A BIT MORE
DEFERENCE THAN THEY USUALLY DO
WITH CONGRESSIONAL REFERRALS.
BECAUSE A LOT OF TIMES
REFERRALS COME OVER TO THE DOJ,
AND THEY ARE KIND OF, LIKE OKAY,
THAT'S NICE.
BUT THIS IS A MASSIVE
INVESTIGATION THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS UNDERTOOK.
IT'S HUGE AMOUNTS OF EVIDENCE,
HUGE AMOUNTS OF WITNESS TO
IDENTIFY.
I THINK IT'S THE DETAIL THAT
ACCOMPANIES THE REFERRALS
THEMSELVES AND THE REPORT THAT
WILL GIVE A ROADMAP FOR DOJ.
DOJ HAS BEEN KIND OF LATE TO
THIS PARTY.
AND THEY ARE PLAYING CATCH-UP.
BUT THAT DETAIL COULD BE VERY
HELPFUL TO THEM AND WILL PUT A
LOT OF PRESSURE ON THEM AS
WELL.
>> I'M GOING TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT MORE ABOUT THAT.
BECAUSE YOU'VE GOT JACK SMITH,
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
HE'S ALREADY OFF RUNNING WITH
THIS PROBE, RIGHT?
WE KNOW THAT.
WE ARE HEARING THAT THERE COULD
BE ADDITIONAL CHARGES PROPOSED
BY THE COMMITTEE.
COULD THESE REFERRALS JAM UP
THE DOJ'S WORK AT THIS POINT?
DOES IT POLITICIZE THE DOJ'S
WORK, CREATING A PERCEPTION
THAT PERHAPS DOJ IS PRESSURED
BY THIS COMMITTEE?
ALTHOUGH IT IS BIPARTISAN --
THOUGH IT IS>> I DON'T THINK ITP
THEIR WORK.
THEY HAVE TO GET THERE ANYWAY.
AND IT SHOULD PROVIDE THEM, AT
THE VERY LEAST, WITH SOME
ADDITIONAL EVIDENCE OR LEADS
THAT THEY MAY NEED TO FOLLOW.
BUT THEY WOULD HAVE TO GO THERE
ANYWAY.
SO, I DON'T THINK THAT ASPECT
WILL JAMJOOM UP.
BUT POLITICIZE IT?
MERRICK GARLAND AND JACK SMITH
ARE IN THIS POSITION OF IF YOU
DO, IF YOU DON'T.
IT'S ALREADY POLITICIZED.
I THINK THE PROBLEM HERE FOR
MERRICK GARLAND IS THAT HE'S
TRIED TO INSULATE THE
DEPARTMENT BY APPOINTING A
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
THAT IN ACT IN AND OF ITSELF
WAS VIEW TO BE A POLITICAL ACT.
AND THE AMOUNT OF DETAIL THAT
IS GOING TO COME OUT IN THIS
REPORT IS GOING TO MAKE IT VERY,
VERY DIFFICULT FOR HIM OR JACK
SMITH TO ACTUALLY DECLINED TO
PROSECUTE.
BECAUSE THE PUBLIC HAS BEEN
EDUCATED.
THERE IS GOING TO BE A LOT OF
DETAIL.
IT'S GOING TO BE A QUESTION FOR
THEM OF PICKING AND CHOOSING,
WHAT IS SOMETHING THEY REALLY
THINK THEY CAN GET CONVICTION
CONVICTIONS ON?
THE ONES THEY DON'T CHOOSE OR
THE ONES THEY DO CHOOSE WILL BE
VERY HEAVILY POLITICIZED.
>> SO THEN WHICH OF THESE
CHARGES THAT THE COMMITTEE IS
EXPECTED TO REFER TO DOJ
CARRIES THE MOST WEIGHT,
LEGALLY?
>> I THINK, PROBABLY, IT'S THE
INSURRECTION, I THINK, IS
LIKELY --
>> REALLY?
>> AND CERTAINLY, THE
OBSTRUCTION OF THE OFFICIAL
PROCEEDING CHARGE CARRIES A LOT
OF WEIGHT.
THERE IS A VERY DIFFERENT,
DIFFERENT PIECES OF PROOF.
WITH INSURRECTION, YOU PROBABLY
NEED MORE OF A LINK TO TRUMP
HIMSELF.
BUT AS A FORMER PROSECUTOR, ONE
THING I WOULD BE THINKING ABOUT
IS HOW TO EXPLAIN THIS BEST TO
A JURY.
SO, THERE IS A HUGE AMOUNT OF
LEGAL ANALYSIS THAT THEY ARE
DOING.
LOTS OF COMMENTATORS AND
ANALYSTS ARE DOING IT ABOUT
WHAT TYPE OF CHARGE WOULD
REALLY FIT THESE FACTS.
BUT YOU ALSO HAVE TO STEP BACK
AND THINK, HOW DO I EXPLAIN
THIS TO A JURY?
WHAT IS GOING TO MAKE SENSE TO
THEM?
OBSTRUCTING THE PROCEEDING?
INSURRECTION?
SEDITIOUS CONSPIRACY?
THOSE ARE THE KINDS OF THINGS
YOU REALLY HAVE TO THINK ABOUT.
BECAUSE YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO PROVE THAT AND TALK TO
PEOPLE ABOUT.
IT
>> YEAH, IT'S A REMINDER.
EVEN THOUGH YOU THINK SOMEONE